[موسيقى]
تربطنا الطيور
بالحياة لمجرد حقيقة أنها تستطيع
الطيران وحقيقة أن هناك 11000 نوع
من جميع الأنواع والأحجام ،
ما لا
يعجبني أنا باتريشيا زاريتا ، أنا الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركة Birdlife International
نحن في مكان ساحر
يطلق عليه اسم حديقة دونالد الوطنية ، نحن
في الجزء الجنوبي من إسبانيا ،
إنها واحدة من أهم الأراضي الرطبة
في أوروبا بأكملها وهي حقًا
جنة آمنة للطيور
التي يقولون إنها ملياري طائر باستخدام
إفريقيا أوراسيا  مسار الطيران هذا هو مسار الطيران
الذي يمتد من جنوب إفريقيا
وصولاً إلى أوروبا وآسيا ،
هذه هي محطة التوقف دونانا هي
المكان الذي تزود فيه بالوقود ، أعني أن هذه هي
الطرق السريعة التي تستخدمها هذه
الطيور كل خريف وكل
ربيع  لأنهم بحاجة إلى العثور على
أماكن أكثر أمانًا للعش ، وأماكن أكثر دفئًا
لفصل الشتاء
عندما نلتقطهم على الشبكة ،
يمكننا أن نطوقهم ، يمكننا مراقبة
عدد الطيور القادمة وما نوع
الأنواع القادمة ومن ثم صنع
الاستنتاجات حول السكان
يساعدنا هذا على فهم عدد الطيور
التي تستخدم الدونانا عندما تهاجر ،
لذلك هذا هو طائر الدخلة الذي جاء
من أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء الكبرى.
سنوات
والأراضي الرطبة ليست استصلاحًا ولكن أيضًا
الزراعة الصناعية التي
تمتص الكثير من المياه من الخزان الجوفي
مما يخلق أزمة مطلقة في هذا
الفضاء المهم للغاية للطبيعة ،
أعني أن هذا النوع من
الزراعة المكثفة والمكثفة
يتعارض تمامًا مع ما هو النظام الطبيعي
لديك صفوف وصفوف وصفوف من
الفراولة ، نعم تبدو جميعها
لذيذة بشكل لا يصدق ، لكنها مثل
سطح القمر ، فهذه ليست طبيعة ،
فنحن نرى السكان الذين ولدوا
غير قادرين على التنفس بعد الآن ، ولم يعد هناك
أي تكاثر خلال السنوات الماضية للحصول على
شعر شارب ، على سبيل المثال التي استخدمت
لإنجاب آلاف الآلاف من الأطفال هنا
منذ خمس
سنوات لم يعد هذا يحدث بعد الآن
[موسيقى]
ما نحتاج إليه  ما عليك القيام به هو مجرد خطوة إلى الوراء وإعادة
التفكير في النظام حتى نتمكن من إعادة
توازنه وهذا هو بالضبط نوع
الزراعة الذي نحتاجه للحفاظ على
صحة هذه الأراضي الرطبة مثل التبرع حتى
نحافظ على اتصال
مسار الطيران
عبر  الحفاظ على هذه الطريقة
التقليدية في إنتاج مزارع الكروم
، لا توجد خطوط ري هنا ، فهم
لا يحتاجون إلى مبيدات حشرية ضارة ،
وهم ينتجون هذا المنتج
المذهل القابل للتطبيق اقتصاديًا
للمنتجين المحليين وهو موطن
هذه الطيور المهاجرة الرائعة التي
تأتي من إفريقيا
[  الموسيقى] يمكن
لهذه الأماكن المدهشة أن تتعافى ،
لكن في اللحظة التي تمنح فيها الطبيعة
فرصة للارتداد ، علينا فقط
أن نمنحها فرصة ،
ثم سنحقق ذلك ، وآمل فقط
ألا يكون قد فات الأوان
[موسيقى]
أنت